it is such an exciting time to be a
filmmaker right now I do not believe
that the notion that the cinema is dying
or dead with all this because it's
amazing what technology can do to the
cinematic storytelling when I went to
film school at that time you would go to
film school for two reasons one to get
with a great teachers in fellow geeks
nerds people that you didn't really have
when you went we're in high school with
each other but you got there and you
were the like kind you were a tribe and
you could learn from each other as well
as the teachers and the second reason
you went was to get access to equipment
seriously now you know like we've been
seeing you know your iPhone your
computer is a movie studio and a
distribution outlet and it's so exciting
but what's great about film is it it
constantly reinvents itself you know as
Henry showed us it started as a sheer
novelty of a kind of images moving on
the screen and stuff like that and B
were like you know and and then it went
and every step of the way as a new
technology started being added sound
color what happens is the film grammar
of the storytelling evolves and changes
as well the technology goes directly
with the evolution of the storytelling
the way films kind of look you know it
started with if you've seen the the you
know in museums and the new Academy
Museum will have them but but you know
the old 35mm in motion picture cameras
and then when they got into color with a
three-strip Technicolor were three
strips of thirty five-millimeter we're
going through one cam
these things weighed hundreds of pounds
and they had to be on dollies and cranes
and I like that that was the film
grammar of the day because of the
limitations of the technology that the
films were being shot that set up what
we've kind of learned is film grammar
and and then as it came on to the
lighter cameras you know of handheld
cameras of steadicams of on and on on
even all the way down to now you know
we've been studying trying to figure out
how to do in the computer you know what
is it there's a unique thing to a GoPro
there's a unique thing to an iPhone and
the way things are shot the way it's
held and it just gives it a vibrancy
that you've never been able to have
before and I believe that new film
grammar is going to be coming from these
these things the same goes for editing
you know I remember when um when MTV
first came out it introduced an
unbelievable style of editing that that
had never been done before the quick
cuts and so on because it was made for
television not made for the big screen
so you can get get by with really really
fast cuts well it made its way to the
big screen it fundamentally changed the
way films are shot if you look at you
look at great like car chases say and
one of the most famous is Bullitt
mm I mean in comparison to some of the
new stuff now it's like oh my god it's
so fast it's like it evolves it changes
and it's because in great part because
of the technology you know in my own
field in animation a seminal film you
know the history of animation is Snow
White in the Seven Dwarves
you know Walters his first
feature-length film people thought Walt
was in sane
it you mean you would actually people
aren't gonna sit still for a
feature-length cartoons are you nuts
you know but Walt was a visionary Walt
saw beyond you know what people were
used to they were used to the short
cartoon and it's interesting how people
the general public cannot see beyond
what they're used to
there's a famous statement that Henry
Ford says that before the Model T if you
ask people what they want they would say
a faster horse my own partner at Pixar
for 25 years Steve Jobs cuz he never
liked market research never did market
research for anything he said it's not
the Audax his job to tell us what they
want in the future is for us to tell
them what they want in the future if you
use technology correctly you can change
opinions overnight it's a great
statement I love is that you only get
one chance to make a first impression
and first impressions are nearly
impossible to get people off of if they
have the wrong impression and remember
when I first saw computer animation it
wasn't being used for much at the time
it was really geometric really sterile
cold but I was blown away by it not by
what I was seeing but the potential I
saw in it that it was true three
dimensionality with a control that we
had hand-drawn animation there have been
stop-motion animation for years but as
all straight-ahead animation didn't
quite have the same life that a classic
hand-drawn and Disney animated film had
I saw the potential in computer
animation and it was like this is great
you know this is a great everybody can
you see this and everything like it
looks like it's too sterile no I don't
like it you know and like and I realized
they were judging from what exactly they
were
you know people really always push back
saying is too cold too sterile in the
early days of computer graphics it found
its way into special effects and but if
you remember in the early days they only
use computer graphics for showing a
computer readout the inside of a the
inside of a computer or something that
was meant to be computer-generated but
there was there were some people who
didn't understand the medium and thought
it could do everything it could there
was his company that tried in sold
Disney when they were making a movie
called something wicked this way comes
on they had worked on Tron did some
effects and they had very charismatic
kind of effects guy that convinced them
that they could create this magical
circus that would erect itself this evil
circus comes to town and so Disney body
a not and they they worked for a very
long time I they very dear friend
working on it and it was way beyond what
the computer could do at that time when
it came you know when it they could they
finished the sequence and it was cut in
I remember seeing this I got to see the
rough cut of it it was like you know
beautifully shot you know period film
going up to thing all of a sudden it's
like what is this I felt like spaceships
were landing or something was so cold
and sterile and had no reality to it at
all and they end up cutting the entire
sequence out of the film it's not it's
on you know somewhere buried you know in
the earth somewhere it is did not make
it in the final film that set back
computer graphics in the the effects
world years because everybody remembered
that experience and it wasn't it it was
because people didn't under
stand what the technology could do about
six years after that I was working at
Lucasfilm computer division and Dennis
Mira the brilliant Dennis Muren effects
director at ILM came over to me and he
said we have this effect in a film
called young Sherlock Holmes Steven
Spielberg produced Barry Levinson
directing we don't know how to do it I'm
thinking computer graphics and it was a
a very old stained glass window in
English Church where a priest gets shot
with a dart starts loosening and a
stained glass knight jumps out made of
glass jumps out of the window and
menaces him down the center aisle of the
church caused him to get scared so much
he runs out and gets run over by a
carriage had to feed put the fear in God
in the fear and him so much that he
would run him eventually to his death it
was only six shots we said let's try it
and it was some of the hardest things
we've ever did but I'll never forget
when it came out effects industry people
from all over the world had no idea how
it was done but it worked it fit in
there it was nominated for an Oscar for
Best Visual Effects and I'll never
forget Siskel and Ebert back then where
they got to choose their their their
Oscars remember they used to do that
back then and Gene Siskel sat there and
was like I have no idea how they did
that but that is amazing you know and
Roger cuz I know how they did it I'll
tell you it goes I don't want to know it
was that really funny but we were so so
excited it was but it was like really
focusing on that you know understanding
the technology and pushing it to places
that we couldn't but it was the goal was
to make it invisible the technology
invisible when we became Pixar 1986 and
we started working towards our first
feature-film I remembered all those
projects and I was blessed by number one
loving the the medium of computer
animation just so interested in it and
working with the people who basically
invented much of computer animation and
we were pushing it all along so we
really understood what the computer
could and could not do and so at that
time when we rendered things everything
kind of looked plasticky I mean we all
know that because of the Monday Night
Football and ABC News and all the the
flying logos that was going around and
so we started thinking about a subject
matter that lent itself to the medium at
that time everything looks like plastics
so what if the characters were made of
plastic what if they were toys and it's
one of the reasons why we kind of leaned
into toy is becoming alive as a subject
for our very first film feature film Toy
Story and if you watch it to this day
you know yeah if you really know CG you
look at the people are weird they're the
humans are always the weirdest the
hardest to create and back then it was
really impossible but it was a story was
not about them we say we had feet in
hands and that was about a few K tional
and faces it was about the toys that
lent himself to the medium at that time
and we chose toys that really kind of
worked for that and in fact it was
better in CG than any other medium we
could have done because we could make
Buzz Lightyear field like is made of
plastic in ball and socket joints and we
had screws and scratches and decals and
all this stuff that you could not have
done in any other medium and so when it
came out our you know our main focus was
was not the technology what I was scared
about was it that people would be like
oh it's the first computer
in the feature film and we made sure
that Disney and all around the world
that you don't sell it as a first CG
film you sell it as a really great
motion picture because that's how we
made it we we really focused on on the
story and hiding the technology and it
came out and in people loved it and you
watch it today and it's just as
entertaining as a day it came out it's
by the way in November early 20 years
old so it makes a lot of you feel really
old yeah and and so if you do it right
the first time like I said you have only
one chance to make a first impression
unlike this that Something Wicked This
Way Comes experience it took years
before someone was willing to try CG and
effects again Toy Story was the number
one film of that year 1995 that came out
was a huge hit and everybody started
looking at this as a viable filmmaking
medium overnight the opinion changed
because the technology was used in the
right way telling the right story we
can't wait we were trying to guess we're
coming up on the 20th anniversary we're
trying to figure out like how many CG
animated feature films have been made
and released in the world today and we
were thinking had been over 100 some 255
and 20 years that blew us away too you
know um I Alfred Hitchcock is one of my
favorite filmmakers and one of the
reasons why I've studied and admired his
films is that guy used new technology in
incredible ways but it was completely
invisible and everything he made
completely invisible but you study the
film you realize there's no way he could
have made that film that shot without
that technology but he didn't want you
to notice he did not want you to notice
it
when we focus on entertaining people in
new ways and if you focus on the
technology too much you get caught up as
I tell you technology is so much fun and
it's so sexy
and so you could caught up into it but
but there there's a side to it that you
can't forget that it's not the
technology that entertains people it's
what you do with the technology and and
it's really important I believe to make
the technology invisible but have it
really push to do something new and so
people just looking and go wow what's
that that's amazing and that's when you
really I think make real breakthroughs
um if you really love a technology if
you really really really really love a
technology then dig into it learn as
much as you can it's fun I mean that's
what I did with CG I mean I was trained
by these great Disney artists I drew and
it was all about story character drawing
all that stuff but when I got into the
computer graphics I was like oh my god
this is so much fun and I wanted to
learn as much as I could you know I
didn't feel like I couldn't program but
I wanted to understand it wait how does
particle systems work how did the
renderer work how did my hey all this
stuff because then I would start the
more you dig into the technology the
more you learn it you are going to get
ideas that you would have never thought
of without knowing your technology and
start thinking about things you know the
kind of shots you can get from an iPhone
that you cannot get with any other
camera use it GoPros use it you know be
inspired by it try things you know it's
digital get another memory card for god
sakes
you know and it's like you will start
creating ideas that just start lending
itself to this thing and start looking
new when you start doing something
that's really truly new you will hear
this it's not going to work you will
hear that it's not going to work
Walt Disney hurt it I heard it with CG
people are going to sit still for it so
cold computer animations so cold really
no I don't think so you know it was it
you think about it it's true for color
sound feature-length animation
CG I mean it's like the first you know
we're the first feature film shot on an
iPhone that's not going to work yeah
it's going to work it's going to be
awesome first feature film shot with a
GoPro it's going to be awesome in the
hands of the right people and the reason
why they say this is it's because it's
not what people are used to you know
before the Model T you ask people what
they want they're going to want a faster
horse it's not what they're used to I
remember sitting with Steve and he was
sitting there again and he would like
look off and wax poetically sometime and
just think it was so fun to hear what he
would say any cuz you know what
everybody has a cell phone but everybody
I know hates their cell phone but we all
have them because I want to make a phone
that people love and that was the
origins of the iPhone it didn't come
from market testing or yeah it just came
from this thing I want to make something
people love
can you imagine life without this now I
mean my god what it started working
with CG you know I could not wait for
the tools to become commonplace in the
early days when it was um you know when
SIGGRAPH was the only place that you
could go and see computer graphics it
was always fun and everybody would cheer
for you know reflective clear balls
floating over a checkerboard and stuff
and be amazed by it you know and it was
in a world where was interesting because
it was a world where all of the the art
and the CG was being created by the the
the guys who are writing the program
there was no such thing as off-the-shelf
software there was no tools available
people writing their software and then
creating it and they were kind of the
artistic guys within the computer world
and and they would um and they they were
just showing off the technology and I
kept thinking myself it's like yeah but
they're really ugly
it's like boring you know let's
entertain people and I couldn't wait
because I always viewed the technology
is simply a tool can you imagine the guy
who invented the pencil and all of the
things that that invention has brought
the world and that's what I was feeling
like with CG I couldn't wait to get it
just in the hands of everybody to see
what they would do and it's it's that
you know we've heard the term disruptors
a lot right lately I loved when Steve
went back to Apple the first ad before
he had any products out he just changed
their whole advertising and I think
different campaign and I think that's
one of the most brilliant advertising
campaigns because it was not about a
product it was about a way of thinking
in in seeing and feeling Steve came to
me privately when he was they just
bought next his company neck saddled it
and they invited him they wanted to come
back to be interim see
oh and he asked my permission I was so
like touched right because Pixar was one
of his babies and he spent a lot of time
with us and he went there and we were
talking about it and he said simply I
asked him do you want to go you want to
do this and he said he said yeah so I
think the world would be a better place
with Apple in it and he was feeling at
the time that that may not survive can
you imagine a world without Apple in it
and the product said they brought you
know and excuse me for any PC users out
there it's like I'm I'll be well admit
I'm really biased but but you know the
medium in which we use is really just
simply tools for expressing your art
your goal as a filmmaker is to entertain
it's and to entertain people is about
story it's about characters it's about
connecting with that audience is making
that connection where you really deeply
entertain audience but it's not just an
art form that we're in it's a business
it is the film business in turn
entertaining stuff simply just does
better it does better you know if you
can make people laugh and cry and feel
things with a film you make you will be
successful no matter what no matter what
medium you've created it no matter any
way you've distributed it doesn't matter
it all comes down to your knowledge
skills what makes a good story how can I
tell it properly you know people get so
excited about new technologies
you know I've had the question so many
times with young people it's like ah you
know when I want to do computer on what
software should I use or like that I go
you know what in your lifetime the
software and the technology would change
so drastically it doesn't matter what
matters is when you're young and you get
excited about this learn the
fundamentals it sounds so boring to
people to young people when they have
they can make a movie so quickly and
release it to the world and get millions
of likes
it's so boring I know how to do that
trust me you don't there's the
fundamentals of good storytelling the
fundamentals of film grammar the even
though it's made with old Mitchell
cameras and stuff like that learn it
learn the fundamentals of animation
learn the fundamentals of physics and
things like that of basic color basic
design the more you get in that this is
a foundation of the building you know of
your career the more that you understand
the fundamentals then as you get into
new technology you'll know exactly what
to do with them and your work will not
be about the technology
it'll be about connecting and
entertaining people and it doesn't
matter the length of your film thirty
seconds five minutes twenty two minutes
feature-length it needs a story it's a
beginning a middle and an end and needs
to really deeply connect with people but
there is big differences between
storytelling at 30 seconds or a feature
film big differences when we did we we
went from short films we did a series of
short films in the beginning of Pixar we
did television commercials and then we
were expect we are thinking the next
step for us what to do it like a
Christmas special and so we thought
about you know that this is what accept
what we need to do but but really it was
you know we made a deal with Disney and
Steve and it is new at the time and we
just threw something deep in and we were
developing a feature film it was amazing
what we didn't know you know but but I
went back to my traditional training
that I had learned from my mentors Frank
Thomas and Ollie Johnston and the great
Disney animators that they were still
working at the studio and I started
there in the fundamentals of animation
that they kept talking about because I
would go to them my drawing was okay it
wasn't great you know and I'll go to
them for help with the scene we're
working on and Ollie Johnston would take
and flip this big stack of things and
look at it and he would turn to me and I
was expecting some thing about arcs and
lines and silhouette valley and all that
stuff and he would turn he goes John
what's the character thinking and it was
amazing to me that that just that simple
statement it was like it was not about
the drawing it was never about the
drawing to them it was about that
character and what it's thinking and
through pure movement they taught me to
bring a character to life and give it an
emotion a personality a uniqueness and
it was done through just pure motion and
so when I started working with a
computer I just brought that technology
with me and as we started developing the
story it was always about emotion it was
always about emotion from the day one
with Toy Story it's about emotion making
you feel and that's what you know I've
admired Walt Disney so much my whole
life and part of it is because he
entertained people like no other person
in history has ever done the way that he
makes you feel when you watch his movies
the way he makes you feel the way he
makes you feel when you walks when you
go through that tunnel under the train
station
Disneyland and you're transported the
way makes you feel it's about emotion
you know in that connection you know
while always said for every laugh there
should be a tear felt like that core
emotion that would became the hallmark
of what we tried to do at Pixar to do
with a new technology I think the
biggest thing for us is that we studied
films we watched films religiously we
were making we with Toy Story it was a
buddy picture we watched everybody
picture we could find and analyzed it
good ones and it's very important to
watch bad ones to know seriously is very
important you watch a bunch of good ones
and watch a few bad ones and pretty soon
you'll start seeing huh this one defiant
ones did this I'm not going to say it
these other films did that and that's
why it doesn't quite work interesting
okay and you start understanding what
they did any more and more and don't
copy things it's about understanding and
learning um very very very important do
not work in a vacuum do not work in a
vacuum right you may be either filmmaker
and doing something wrong you know but
you have to surround yourself with
trusted people you have to you know you
get so immersed in your work you will
everybody does you get so emotional in
your work I guarantee you you will you
will not be able to see the forest from
the trees frankly you'll be stunning the
pine needles and worrying about them and
you need someone to help you back up and
take a look at the forest and see where
things are working or not working and
you need to surround yourself with
people whose judgment you trust and they
can be brutally honest with you and you
have to be able to look showing as an
artist showing unfinished work to people
is really difficult is really hard
it always is hard it always will be hard
it never gets an easy
but you have to do it understand my
partner at creative partner Pixar has
this fantastic freight so to use all the
time be wrong as fast as you can trust
me when you go from an outline to a
treatment your first treatment sucks
and you do revisions and talk to people
like that you get something working
really great go to your first draft of
the script it sucks you do it a bunch of
times and for us we go to story reels
the first story reel sucks but but the
longer you go it's I'm not quite ready
yet let me give me a little more time
give me a little more time like that
it's not going to help the problem right
you're just going to be polishing you're
not going to be seeing where it's not
working get it up there throw it up
there as fast as you can
talk about it tear back down put it back
up there keep doing this surround
yourself with really people that you
trust you know be thirsty for knowledge
be thirsty for knowledge you will always
make your work better you know the
market is changing really really really
really quickly and really who knows what
the business will look like ten years
from now you know but I know one thing
for sure that if you create characters
people connect with and tell stories
that deeply entertain and move them the
audience will come they'll come no
matter how you show it and they'll keep
coming back in this business remember
the simple thing I believe truly success
breeds autonomy the more that you can do
this and show time and time and time
again that you can deeply entertain
people you will be able to keep making
your art and people will leave you alone
trust me they do success breeds autonomy
and so really you know if you make great
work you can also you could set the
terms to of like what you want to be
doing so it's stuff that really moves
and excites you so be inspired by
amazing new technology be inspired about
all the stuff the speaker's talked about
like this but make sure that you're
entertaining people make sure you
understand the fundamentals of
storytelling in film grammar and
animation or whatever design color
understand those because that is what
you will use with the new tools to
create things that really deeply
entertain people thank you very much